what is 5G including sub 6 gigahertz 5G
and millimeter wave 5G how does it work
and maybe the most important question is
how will it change the world in the
coming years when we set ourselves to
develop 5G and you know we look at this
every generation of Technology had a
problem to be solved right so you
mentioned to g to g challenge the
challenge of CDMA was can we give every
person on earth a cell phone that was
can you get to a technology that you can
basically allow everyone to have a
mobile phone 3G was about the ability to
connect that to the internet I think 4G
was broadband and with 4G was about had
the ability for you to have a computer
in the palm of your hand we just talk
about that 5G the challenge was a little
bit different
yes how do we build a technology for a
society that is going to be 100
connected to the cloud how do we provide
a technology that is going to be the
last mile connectivity for everything so
5G is it's basically been designed
eliminate all issues with data
congestion whether you are in in uh
Stadium we talk about soccer you were in
a stadium and everyone should be ability
to have access to broadband so deal with
congestion deal with the fact that not
only people but billions of things need
to be connected
create a technology that for the first
time in Wireless you could deliver
Mission critical services
Wireless used to up to 4G is its best
effort in 5G it can guarantee that
you're connected with the cloud and then
the last point of that
is provide this fabric that will allow
us as a society to look at things that
are not connected and say that's the
exception that's why we made a
comparison in the early days of 5G that
that's going to be like electricity
right now you don't have a discussion
about what is the use cases for
electricity you don't talk about that
anymore it just assume it's there and
that's how we think about everything
connected to the cloud that's what 5G is
and that's the role of 5G
so first of all everything connected to
the cloud is interesting because the
space of everything is constantly
increasing correct you know I don't
think the refrigerator over there it
looks kind of smart but I don't think
it's connected yet
uh to the cloud so this includes
Internet of Things what is the full
space of everything the full space of
everything is it's uh maybe going back
to
where you start defining qualcon is
about Communications and Advanced
Computers for low power devices and can
we make everything smart you know it can
ranges from the robot you have right now
on the floor to your refrigerator to to
a camera to uh
you know machines in manufacturing uh to
retail
Etc like I can give you some examples
when when we think of something as
simple as going to to the grocery shop
we see technology now with something
that this stuff we've been working with
companies like Walmart electronic shelf
labels the ability for you to have Smart
cameras they can look at shelves and can
the camera smart enough to say some
product needs to be replenished ability
to see was there so it's about really
providing processor connectivity
artificial intelligence to everything
and uh I think that's one of the largest
uh addressable markets we have for
technology because you can't really
Define everything right exactly it's a
nice Market because it keeps growing
potentially exponentially in speed
um
what about coverage so how are we doing
on the everything part so you know there
is like I mentioned sub six gigahertz 5G
and there's a millimeter wave 5G so not
all 5G is made the same so there's a
speed there's a there's a bandwidth
thing and then there's coverage how many
people get to enjoy
um today and how does the progress of
the next 5 10 20 30 50 years you think
looks like in terms of coverage great
topic conversation so let's talk about
this
when I meet with Regulators across the
globe I I tell them uh resistance is
futile allocate every Spectrum to
wireless every Spectrum needs to be
allocated to wireless the reality is
when we start moving from CDMA to ofdma
we knew that there's this industry has
done a lot to get more bits per Hearts
but the reality is uh the massive amount
of improvements that is required in
capacity and in speed uh you need more
Spectrum you know there's there's not so
much we can rely on more bits per Hearts
who just need more spectrum and if you
look
for example what carriers since the 2G
era they participate in different
license and auctions and every spectrum
they accumulated from 2g or 3G or 4G
all of that you may be able to get one
or two channels Max of subjects uh which
is a channel is about 100 megahertz or
200 megahertz and that's it so we we
need more Spectrum so 5G has been
designed to work across every Spectrum
from the low frequency bands that's we
call the sub six but you needed more you
needed to go to the millimeter wave so
that's why 5G is a technology that you
can deploy from 450 megahertz as an
example or 600 or 700 all the way to in
the 42 gigahertz and that's where
millimeter wave comes into the picture
now
let's now connect this to your question
about coverage of 5G the easiest thing
to do uh is to deploy 5G in the new
Spectrum you can get uh which is uh in
the sub six you see bands being
auctioned across the globe into 3.5
gigahertz there's nothing special about
the band is this the only one that was
available because everything else has
been useful 4G and you can deploy on
that go into existing cell towers and
just put a new equipment without having
to build new towers but when we go to
Technologies such as millimeter wave
then you have to build more dense
networks you need to build more stations
because a deployment in that case looked
like a Wi-Fi deployment it's almost like
Wi-Fi access points when you need to
build more stations you need permits you
need to build fiber so it takes more
time to densify so what you see
happening is coverage has been built
fast with subjects across the globe now
the United States also have sub 6 so
that gets you to coverage very fast but
millimeter wave it's moving and uh if I
will say for example Verizon United
States has had a leadership uh in
building Miller Middle wave it takes
time I'll say cities like uh Chicago
Manhattan starting to get coverage it
will be a process over a number of years
as you build uh those different access
points type networks but is inevitable
there's not enough Spectrum so every 5G
operator is just a matter of time will
have millimeter wave as well resistance
is futile okay so uh for military wave
we need density of access points and
what's the biggest resistance
for Qualcomm
for human civilization is it uh
politicians Regulators Federal
Regulators is it uh individual humans is
it not enough money from the consumer
perspective like what who is the biggest
pain in the butt from a Qualcomm
standpoint but answering the question
about what it takes to build all this
technology I think Regulators across the
board understood the importance of 5G I
have not met a regulator that said it's
really important to be late on 5G I
don't think anybody wants to be late on
5G and as a result we've seen enormous
amount of progress in getting Spectrum
allocated to 5G I think the real issue
is the time that it takes to build
infrastructure you know investment in 5G
infrastructure special wave is like
building roads and ports it's critical
infrastructure and those things take
time like one of the number one obstacle
you're going to hear from operators is
site permit you know sometimes they have
to negotiate municipal quality by
municipality about permits to get new
cell sites but you know the networks
will be densified and and you're going
to need all of that capacity for the
promise of the full immersive augmented
reality that will replace phones and
everything being connected 100 of the
time this would not be a conversation
with the CEO if I did not ask
questions that make you nervous
some people raise concerns about there
not being enough studies about the
effects of 5G on the human body
is 5G safe
look uh I have a very simple answer
to to this question
as we built new capabilities such as 5G
power is going down
especially when you think about reducing
the number of Base stations the networks
becoming more dense so as you do that
the the power becomes lower if your
phone radiated from Power radiated from
the phone and from the tower as you get
closer to the tower you don't need that
much power to reach the tower so as as
we move from 4G to 5G I think we see a
reduction in the amount of powers
required to close the radio link now
also you have a number of organizations
the FCC for example has rigorous
programs which they do a lot of tests to
validate uh you know the safety of those
devices and I think we have has been a
model for other countries to also to
adopt the same things uh
solar's been around for a number of
decades now I think smartphones are most
beloved device today
and I I would argue how it's difficult
to answer those questions because you
but I'll argue that the data to date
have we've seen in 3G and 4G
um you know has uh shown that uh a lot
of the initial concerns were not valid
we look at 5G even though it's new it's
just less power so we're looking from
from a physics standpoint first of all
from a physics from a biology
perspective
there's a lot of evidence there's
studies that show that it's not uh
dangerous that it is in fact safe
however the concern that people have is
when you scale technology exponentially
um how will that change human
civilization I mean that doesn't apply
to 5G that applies to every technology
how you said smartphone is the most
beloved device but love sometimes hurts
that's uh the impact on society we don't
know and and there's a little bit of
fear there's both excitement and fear
it's a great topic of conversation
actually so so let me give you my
perspective on this and you started to
see something exactly happening right
now so let me step back
and let's talk about the fact that we
are in a fully interconnected society
that when when uh when you look of the
situation today we talk about
smartphones uh largest uh development
platform uh so much now of our life uh
we are connected to the smartphone and
as a result and we are all connected and
we're connected and then we're building
digital twins of everything right so so
when you look at that picture when you
look at the picture this connected
Society
uh you started to have the following
thoughts which I think are very healthy
which means in the same way that in the
physical world
you're entitled to some right to have
obligations and there's a lot of uh
things that protect your your integrity
I think as a rule we're going to see the
society evolving so those things extend
to your digital being of people and
things and I think just natural it's
just natural uh it's just a natural path
and you started to see things like that
for example the Europeans has done uh a
lot in this area I'll say the Europeans
probably ahead in the United States and
thinking about privacy loss digital
privacy as well most recent the dma the
digital markets act which I think is a
great thing I think we're we believe
there's incredible uh thought and to
enable ability to regulate the digital
market so that there's Innovation and
competitions and not not a single
company uh can control all the data and
then decide you know uh how things are
going to be work on the digital realm
and even if we think about the potential
of things like the metaverses we're
connecting physical and digital spaces
so I think it's a natural evolution of
course regulate regulation and laws I
always follow technology but but the
fact that we're uh moving toward
interconnected Society there's there's
no going back uh we are a fully
interconnected Society but there is
opportunity uh to think about how the
digital to win uh should people people
and governments should think about it so
that we get the best of a technology we
doubt that any downside yeah so when you
say digital twin that's one of the other
things you're excited about which is the
metaverse are basically building worlds
in the in the digital space and you have
to start to think about all the basic
human rights that transfer from our
physical meat Vehicles out to the
digital copies of ourselves
representations of ourselves it's really
important to think about the thing you
mentioned about Regulators that has been
this is me speaking frustrating is like
you said they follow technology so
sometimes they don't get the technology
at all
so they're very clumsy in writing laws
that censor that technology in
interesting ways they mean good but they
can do a lot of unintended damage now
both it's a dance it's a beautiful dance
but I just wish governments were better
dance Partners I just see what they're
kind of writing now about regulating
social media and
platforms like YouTube and it's just
really really clumsy they don't
understand how machine learning works I
recommend their systems work and I just
wish they kind of caught up a little
more because it's really important to be
great at regulation
but also it's important to let companies
flourish and embrace this new wave of
technology that that weird dance I I'm
more and more learning looking at public
policy how much positive government can
do and how much clumsy negative it can
do unintentionally just out of sheer
incompetence or lack of curiosity about
tech
that's my rant Regulators I think it's a
valid point
as I said before I think the Europeans
probably have a very good framework but
you know the way the way I'll think
about it we we depend on have the
ability to innovate we depend on the
free markets we depend on the ability to
create uh you know technology that uh
that will be disruptive but at sometimes
I think the tech companies probably
should spend time helping governments
understand helping understand ahead of
time so that they can be better prepared